connaissez-vous le dernier endroit
branché de paris le dernier endroit à la
mode et bien ne cherchez pas autour de
vous il est sous vos pieds dans les
catacombes
c'est très chic et pas cher on y entre
par les bouches d'égout
c'est ce qu'ont fait nos reporters jean
marc dubois et michel c'est l'état guidé
par deux journalistes de l'écho des
savanes
leslie et jean paul lepers allons-y 23
heures un samedi soir quelque part dans
une rue de paris
la dernière sortie à la mode
ap
personne ne regarde maintenant il faut
descendre
et oh bah c'est franchement une bonne
centaine de bars aux unités glissant
pour se retrouver 35 mètres plus bas
là c'est un autre monde
300 km de galeries plus ou moins bien
entretenus les catacombes de paris
on s'y promène on exemple lors on joue à
se faire peur
égal on s'y perd et on y fait des
rencontres
j'ai un bon jour dans sa rue qu'est ce
que vous faites là vous revenez d'où
vous êtes allez vous on a essayé de la
salle s'est depuis lors non c'est un
cutter healy à toutes sortes de choses à
voir dans les catacombes des eaux bien
sur une plage de sable fin des bunkers
datant de la dernière guerre
mais c'est ici que la jeunesse branchée
se retrouvent dans la salle z une
ancienne carrière
la boîte la plus courue de la capitale
en fait ce qui est fascinant c'est de
savoir qui a tout ça sous paris sait
maintenant ce qu'il y avait en fait vous
ça existe tout simplement vous descendez
toujours dans cette tenue nous n'ont pas
toujours assez exceptionnel mais il va
falloir d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on se
munissent de casques de bottes pour
juste pour une question de facilité en
fait parce que j'en ai pu constater
c'est un petit peu ça mais en talons il
apparaît très facile en fait
non
on vient dans la salle z avec tout ce
qu'il faut pour s'amuser et même de la
musique
le samedi soir des groupes rock viennent
exercer leurs talents dans la
discothèque la plus profonde de paris